this video is brought to you by
mansgame.com
manscape created the first all-in-one
men's grooming kit
that makes trimming your bush safe and
easy enter the perfect package
3.0
it comes with the lawnmower 3.0 body
trimmer
with skin safe technology to prevent
manscaping accidents
don't cut your ballsacks they got ball
toner to keep your ball smelling fresh
smells like pus poos no no no no mentos
the crop preserver anti-chafing ball
deodorant the ball deodorant is one of
the most underrated
products in this whole entire collection
and you want to know why this is one of
the most underrated products tell them
to say
because it keeps your balls fresh dry
even after a long day and if you need to
go home and see that special someone
you're not talking about you don't have
time to take a shower
it keeps it fresh you put deodorant on
your armpits
like this so why don't you just put
deodorant
on your ball sack which is way more
sweaty or nastier
that's what i'm talking about dude oh
it features aloe vera and a quick
absorbing gel so it dries clear
and it keeps your balls nice and
moisturized
all day long
oh this is cruelty free
dye free paraben free and also a hundred
percent
vegan all natural baby for everything
that you need to look and smell your
best
go to wwe
jknews to get 20 off plus free
international shipping
we're gonna have a link in the
description box your balls will
thank you
do you guys still do certain things that
you
used to do when you were a kid yeah like
jacking off baby
you jacked off as a baby oh no a lot of
kids do wait how old
yeah a lot of kids touch them from
infant to toddler to like i don't know
just
like is there certain things that y'all
just i think i still hug my blanket
yeah like blankies as uh as i i probably
did when i was like three hey that's
crazy do you ever
think about it you're like i should i
should stop this
no because sleep is baby time
[Laughter]
i have intense affection towards soft
objects
what's intense affection how do you say
he's wiping his mouth
like this tissue like this
that's a good dog
you guys don't do that yeah i get what
you're saying not like a you got a
pillow and then you [ __ ] well if it's
alive you don't want to do this but
because they're not alive you just
squeeze the [ __ ] out of it
that is intense so you treat it as if
the same way you would when you're a kid
or you have something really soft
yeah and then and it's nice to just have
something here
like a baby hmm is it bringing back like
certain nostalgic memories or whatever
like a security blanket yeah security
blanket i had this cat
it [ __ ] was filled with saliva
my it was so disgusting it was the shape
of an oval
but i was hella attached to it and
because it was yours it probably smelled
good to you too
i don't even remember how it smelled it
was my mom was like that [ __ ] is
disgusting and i'm like no i need to
keep it
until what age did you did you have it
with you
i don't know i think there's a age where
you stop doing that
right what age do you think that would
be some people don't do yeah some people
some people still be like sucking their
thumbs and stuff like that as grown
adults what
yeah you've never seen that never seen
that i think the only thing is
squeezing and smelling oh this just
smells like dust
well for uh how do i do this okay for
28 year old damien turner
he has not stopped wearing diapers wow
20. sometimes i'm like i need to put
[ __ ] diapers on
i don't want to move is he does he still
[ __ ] on himself
or he just likes the feeling of a diaper
you know what i don't think they talked
about whether or not he shits in these
diapers but he likes wearing diapers
enough so where he actually goes out in
public with just a t-shirt on and a
diamond
have a hat what yes i'm asking you like
at one point do you stop doing this when
i can use the bathroom is when i stop
true true does that mean like since he
was a child he's never stopped wearing a
diaper or is this like a new like
fetish kind of thing that now as an
adult he's reverting back to that
it's the second one so it is more of a
fetish thing so he started wearing
diapers again when he was 16.
but for a long time he would always
blame his like
uh ibs ability to yeah hold his [ __ ] in
and like just needing to just [ __ ] all
the time as a reason for his parents to
buy him diapers
and uh and so then he started wearing
them at six now he's proudly wearing it
he's proudly wearing it now he's part of
a
a community called uh the diaper i like
that one because it's it's much longer
than that
typey wipeys adults who still wear
diapers pretty close
abdl adult baby diaper lover community
wow yes he's been part of this community
for 10 years there is a
a bunch of adults that like playing
babies like they like to be
babies and [ __ ] i don't know what the
name is called that one chick that we
talked about
oh yeah she was like trying to be all
like she had a gigantic
crib and everything that was so weird
that was really weird so does he make
other people change his diaper how does
it
like what's his thing mommy i did a
poopy they don't go into detail as to
like
how he wears his diaper what he does
with the diamond
is it is it not like easier though like
like let's say
yeah if i if i'm wearing a diaper
there's like the convenience of like all
right i'm not gonna go to the bathroom
i'm just gonna [ __ ] here but then i
gotta clean that up aftermath
there's so much more work wait don't you
just throw it away
yeah but but you're not like oh if you
take a [ __ ]
i'm talking about peeing because like i
hate when you're in the zone
and then you gotta pee you know you have
to break through yeah but even then
even if you pee it's not like it's like
perfectly different
yes like it's a wet towel
a rash from your own [ __ ] and pee what
about what about the diaper that you
were wearing did you ever use it
no oh we should have tried you guys wore
a dice shirt
they were a diaper for a skit diapers
are comfortable that's true
but i should have tried pissing and
[ __ ] in it to see what that feels
like i don't know about [ __ ]
i feel like you could probably do that
in your underwear you could probably do
it right now and you'll have
it's not the same yeah it's not
absorbent and it's not thick
in like where you feel it soak up and
you're like oh dude i feel like i wear
a diaper on once every month why uh
i wore a penny liner i don't wear a pad
but still it feels like [ __ ] diapers
is that the same the same material
same uh absorbent i don't know if it's
as thick because the
diapers we had that [ __ ] was like uh at
least an inch thick
yeah so penny liners are like really
thin but it's still like that like the
material on your skin
okay it's peeing maybe but like isn't it
i mean this guy from 16 and 28 like this
yeah that's like 12 years of like
[ __ ] on himself maybe he doesn't
even pee or [ __ ] in it he just
he likes wearing it but he wears it out
in public he wears it to work so the
whole point of this
article he wears it to work where's it
work he got fired there's a dress code
or for wearing for wearing diapers
at his workplace
so he's been fired in this specifically
he was fired for
let me find it wearing diapers in the
world it's really hard to take a dude
seriously
when he gets up and he's wearing diapers
and he's all like hey bob can i get the
papers from last week and he's just like
damn bro that's weird he can't wear
pants or like a skirt at least
he probably wears pants because he was
he's working at a
he was working at a catering job so
he wears that's not pants over the
diapers but i guess the diapers are so
bulky and like and he walks out
[Music]
[Laughter]
diapers the baby waddle to it it doesn't
like spread your legs out because it's
so thick
you should just imagine i would do that
is there something weirdly psychological
about this that like i'm not
totally understanding oh yeah i'm trying
to understand it too so i think it's a
security blanket thingy yeah i think
it's that too for sure
so in his words he said employment is
hard i'm constantly in and out of jobs
sometimes my employers find my pictures
online or just can't put up with the
fact i'm wearing it i'm wearing a diaper
and acting childish in the workplace so
he's also acting he also acts
you can't do that because that might be
that because i'm like maybe if this guy
is really professional
yeah like and he's the best at his job
like [ __ ] it i can overlook it oh like
the guy who wears heels
i'm trying to cater
why'd you fire me and they're like how
do you get rid of this [ __ ]
yeah he can't be like at the catering
company and it's like a wedding
and he's he brings out the food and then
he spills it he goes uh-uh and he starts
crying
and it's like what the [ __ ] dude he just
pisses himself
he starts pissing himself and it's like
bro what the [ __ ] not again
yeah it's true in the middle of a
[ __ ] wedding too oh jeez
you know yeah and then that sucks
because the company's like come on man
i took a chance on you yeah you're doing
this that's tricky
he's got to be have worn the diaper to
the to the interview too yeah
i called your references they talked
hella [ __ ] but i still took a chance and
i [ __ ] up
right you think you get sponsored by
like diaper brands
like depends diaper brands would want to
associate themselves maybe it's a huge
market you know what i mean if there's a
if there's a society for this
community we got to hit that demo you
know what if he's reached a level of
happiness in those diapers that we just
don't understand though
i don't know the way taika goes like
after he pees he's like he wants to
change his diaper right away
i think he's trying to act all older
than his age though
he's three dude like he's an adult he'll
just feel like i pee pee
change my diaper oh then he like the man
he likes it fresh huh yeah he likes to
fresh
are you guys potty training now oh yeah
so we we we're just doing it at his own
pace so now like if he wants to pee
and if he didn't pee in his diaper he'll
let us know we just take him to the
toilet and he just pees into the toilet
but yeah back to this guy he uh so in
his words dressing and acting like a
baby gives off a very calm relaxing and
safe
vibe it's almost as if you were back in
preschool without a worry in the world
and that's what he's after i could
understand tapping into that
a little bit because that one time
anthony remember when we did the jk
party
uh i'm already scared of where she's
gonna go no psychiatrist the
the one where you you're sitting in the
chair and we all have a rule that you
don't know
or like a thing and then one of them was
where every time you asked a question we
would age
10 years oh yeah until you died and then
you got rebirth
exactly so then those like those few
times that we were like children
children
i could see like tapping into that
innocence of like oh this is like it
feels nice to be a kid again because
you're not
an adult but in that exact same example
it was
relative and you were very conscious of
like what that was making
somebody who like me who wasn't
experiencing that feel so like this
guy's got to be conscious
about other people around him and like
how they might
even lost a few childhood friends he's
like he's lost friends over there
how could he lose childhood friends when
he's a child
i guess he's gotta make new friends then
period he's gotta go get some adulthood
friends
and yeah i don't think any adults wanna
be his friends just other diaper homies
yeah thank god for the internet right i
know yeah i just connect with other
people
significantly less lonely because of the
internet but to
his credit though he's also just [ __ ]
proud to wear diapers good for him
that's bad that's
automatically public you do you
as long as it's like you don't do poo
you know like you do you just don't poop
yeah that's true he said
it's something i've always been into
since i was a kid if i
if i really had to pin it to something
i'd say episode spongebob and tom and
jerry
where they were wearing a diaper for a
gag or a throwaway joke i found it very
appealing and have
pretty much been wearing them since i
was 16. he should probably just go into
entertainment like
this is a place where you can dress
however you want
true such as yours truly
and still be accepted and you just have
to be entertaining that's all it is
as long as you're entertaining that's
fine true and a guy in a diaper is kind
of entertaining like yeah he's got a
good start it's like the punch line is
there
every time you see a dude in a shirt and
and like he wants to be decent so he's
still wearing the shirt right
but then he's having like no no pants
that looks funnier
than a guy that is just shirtless in my
in my opinion that looks way funnier for
sure
i wonder why he doesn't just go full
baby and wear onesies and [ __ ]
and like fire oh i don't know about the
pacifier in the bed but he definitely
wears onesies too and he goes out in
public and he's saying like
yeah people stare but i don't care you
just you know what is it you have
training wheels on his adult sized bike
do they make training wheels for
adult-sized bikes i think sometimes i'm
like i want training wheels just to be
able to stand on a bike and not like
worry about falling over
that'll be funny i think it's called the
tricycle though oh true true true
does he like not allow himself into like
adult places that's
tight he cards himself how old are you
yeah how old is he
mentally oh i think he knows he's 28 no
no like when he's
doing this as a baby he must not think
that he is
like what is he teleporting to right i
have a feeling
like i don't know much other than what
i've told you so far but i have a
feeling that when he is distressed or
like you know feeling
pressure i feel like that's when he
reverts into some form of baby
age two or something yeah because we all
have our i feel useless yeah we all
yeah we do all go through that juice no
because i just imagine like he's in his
house with his family
and a [ __ ] like robber breaks in he's
like oh no
and then he goes he puts on his [ __ ]
onesie he's in the corner
and his mom's like [ __ ] tied up and
[ __ ] he's like help me
help me no not in timely space
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you